>>> THIS MORNING A STUNNING
TRANSFORMATION ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
UKRAINE BREAKING THROUGH RUSSIAN
LINES NEAR KHARKIV AND RETAKING
TOWNS THAT HAVE BEEN UNDER
RUSSIAN CONTROL FOR MONTH.
YOU CAN SEE THEM RAISING A FLAG
IN ONE OF THESE TOUPS.
LET ME SHOW YOU ON THE MAP
EXACTLY WHERE THIS IS TAKING
PLACE.
EVERYWHERE YOU SEE IN YELLOW
HERE IS NOW UNDER UKRAINIAN
CONTROL UNTIL A FEW DAYS AGO IT
WAS ALL UNDER RUSSIAN CONTROL.
THIS HAS HAPPENED WITH STUNNING
REPETTY INCLUDING YOU CAN SEE
RIGHT HERE, THE TOWN, THE CITY
OF IZIUM WHICH WAS A KEY
CONQUEST BY THE RUSSIANS EARLY
ON IN THE CONFLICT, THAT IS NOW
MOSTLY UNDER UKRAINIAN CONTROL.
LET'S GO RIGHT TO CNN'S MELISSA
BELL LIVE IN KHARKIV THIS
MORNING WITH THIS REMARKABLE
TURN AROUND, MELISSA.
>> Reporter: JOHN, QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY.
SOME 3,000 SQUARE KILOMETERS
THAT ARE NOW IN UKRAINIAN HANDS
SAY UKRAINIAN AUTHORITIES.
BUT REMEMBER THAT THIS IS REALLY
HARD FOR US TO VERIFY BECAUSE OF
THE MEDIA BLACKOUT.
JOURNALISTS JUST NOT ALLOWED TO
GET CLOSE TO THE FRONT LINES OF
THOSE COUNTEROFFENSIVES.
AND YET, CNN WAS ABLE TO GET
EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO THE TOWN
JUST TO THE NORTH OF ID YUM THAT
YOU JUST SAW.
WHAT WE FOUND, JOHN, EVEN THOUGH
A UKRAINIAN FLAG HAS BEEN RAISED
SOMEWHERE, IT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THE
FIGHTING IS DONE.
THE TANKS SPOKE TO A HASTY
RUSSIAN RETREAT AS UKRAINIAN
FORCES SWEPT EAST WARDS OVER THE
WEEKEND.
TRIUMPHANTLY RAISING THE FLAG ON
SATURDAY.
LOCAL POLICE FORCES PROVIDING
CNN WITH EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO A
KEY TOWN NOW MEANT TO BE UNDER
UKRAINIAN CONTROL.
WE STILL FEEL UNEASY BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN BOMBED FOR FOUR DAYS
IN A ROW AND NOTHING IS CERTAIN
YET.
WHICH ONLY BECAME CLEARER AS WE
HEADED FURTHER IN.
A FIRST ARTILLERY STRIKE.
TOO CLOSE FOR COMFORT.
THEN A SECOND.
MUCH CLOSER.
THAT WAS THE SOUND OF ARTILLERY
LANDING JUST NEXT TO OUR CAR.
OUR ARMORED CAR.
WE HAVE COME HOPING TO GET TO
THAT FLAG TO SEE WHERE IT HAD
BEEN PLOTTED ONLY YESTERDAY, BUT
AS YOU CAN SEE, THIS SUNDAY
AFTERNOON AND STILL THE SCENE OF
SOME PRETTY FIERCE FIGHTING.
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING THE SOUND
OF OUTGOING ARTILLERY FIRE.
THAT WAS THE SOUND OF INCOMING.
TWO HITS DIRECTLY TARGETING OUR
CAR, SAYS THE POLICEMAN.
TIME TO GO BACK TO WHAT WE HAD
COME TO SEE.
THOSE PARTS OF KHARKIV REGION
FULLY UNDER UKRAINIAN CONTROL.
WHERE AFTER SIX MONTHS OF
OCCUPATION, UKRAINIAN
INVESTIGATORS KNOW ALL TOO WELL
WHAT THEY'LL FIND.
AFTER BUCHA THAT WERE UNDER
RUSSIAN CONTROL FOR ONLY A
MONTH.
YES, ACCORDING TO OUR
INFORMATION, WE ARE RECORDING
WAR CRIMES IN ALMOST EVERY
VILLAGE, HE SAYS.
THIS, THE BODY OF ONE OF TWO
CIVILIANS KILLED IN LATE
FEBRUARY.
AN EARLY VICTIM OF THE INVASION
AND EVIDENCE NOW OF WHAT SIX
CONTINUING HERE IN EASTERN
KHARKIV, EVEN AS YOU SAW THERE
THE FIGHT CONTINUES AND BITTERLY
FOR THE UKRAINIAN FORCES TRYING
TO REGAIN GROUND, JOHN.
>>> THIS MORNING THE U.S.
GROWING CONCERN THAT MOSCOW'S
WEAPONIZATION OF OIL AND GAS
COULD CAUSE DIVISION IN EUROPE'S
UNITED FRONT AGAINST RUSSIA'S
WAR ON UKRAINE.
IT COMES AS EUROPE FACES A TOUGH
WINTER AND SKYROCKETING COSTS
AFTER RUSSIA SHUT OFF FLOWS
THROUGH A KEY PIPELINE.
TELL US ABOUT THE CONCERNS.
>> THEY'RE WARNING OF A TOUGH
WINTER.
EUROPEAN LEADERS ARE SAYING
THERE COULD BE BLACKOUTS ACROSS
EUROPE.
PEOPLE ARE TAKING TO THE STREETS
TO PROTEST THE SKYROCKETING
ENERGY COSTS AND PRESIDENT PUTIN
SHUTOFF FLOWS TO EUROPE LAST
WEEK SAYING HE WON'T TURN THEM
BACK ON UNTIL SANCTIONS ARE
LIFTED.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T SEE ANY REAL SIGNS
THAT EUROPEAN UNITY ON PUNISHING
RUSSIA IS FRACTURING AT THIS
POINT BUT THEY'RE CONCERNED
THAT'S EASY TO SAY AND DO WHEN
IT'S SUMMER.
BUT WHEN IT GETS COLD, THE RISK
OF POLITICAL INSTABILITY
BREAKING OUT AS PRICES GO HIGHER
IS A RISK.
THEY'RE WATCHING IT CLOSELY.
THAT IS WHY LAST WEEK, WHEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONVENED ALMOST
A DOZEN WESTERN LEADERS ON A
CALL, THAT WAS HIS CENTRAL
MESSAGE, IT WAS ABOUT ENERGY,
ABOUT STAYING STRONG, ABOUT HOW
THE UNITED STATES IS WORKING
REALLY AROUND THE CLOCK HERE TO
TRY TO FIND ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
SOURCES FOR EUROPE AS RUSSIA
CONTINUES TO WEAPONIZE OIL AND
GAS AS A RESULT OF THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
THERE ARE LINGERING CONCERNS
THAT EUROPE IS GOING TO NOT BE
ABLE TO COME TO SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT ON THE QUESTIONS OF AN
OIL PRICE CAP OR GAS PRICE CAP
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME COUNTRIES
IN THE EUROPEAN ALLIANCE SAYING
IF WE DO ANYTHING ELSE TO MAKE
RUSSIA ANGRY HERE THEY'RE GOING
TO CUT OFF WHAT LITTLE SUPPLIES
REMAIN TO ALLIES LIKE HUNGARY
FOR EXAMPLE, AUSTRIA ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHAT KIND
OF THING IS GOING TO BE THE LAST
STRAW HERE IN TERMS OF ANYTHING
THAT BREAKS THE WESTERN RESOLVE
HERE.
AS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DURING
THE BREAK IT'S HARDER BECAUSE OF
THE MOMENTUM THAT WE SEE RUSSIA
HAVING HOWEVER WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS -- THAT
WE SEE UKRAINE HAVING I MEAN.
BUT A LOT OF OFFICIALS ARE
SAYING THAT IS ONLY GOING TO
STEEL PUTIN'S RESOLVE TO MAKE
LIFE MORE MISERABLE FOR THE
EUROPEANS AS HE LOSES GROUND IN
UKRAINE AND LIFE GETS HARDER FOR
RUSSIANS AS THEIR ECONOMY TANKS.
>> HARDER TO PULL THE RUG FROM
AN ARMY THAT HAS THE MOMENTUM.
GREAT REPORTING, NATASHA, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.